Esta vez quiero reflexionar sobre algunas
preguntas comunes en las escuelas, por ejemplo,
los estudiantes con frecuencia preguntan,
¿por qué cuando trabajamos con álgebra,
utilizamos letras y no solo números?
Bueno, esa es una muy buena pregunta, sí,
¿por qué usamos tantas "x", "y", "a", "b", "c" cuando estamos iniciando el trabajo con álgebra?
Voy a dejar un momento, para que tú puedas
reflexionar acerca de esto.
Bueno, a mi me gustaría empezar a decir que
a veces tenemos una incógnita, por ejemplo,
cuando digo "x" más 3 es igual a 10 y cuando
planteamos un problema como éste,
es porque en realidad tenemos una incógnita, algo que
no conocemos y queremos resolver,
pero no necesariamente tendría que ser una "x", porque
este espacio más 3 es igual a 10
ó la interrogación más 3 es igual a 10.
Bueno, podríamos utilizar una carita sonriente
también, una carita sonriente más 3 igual a 10.
Necesitamos algún tipo de símbolo
que representa un número.
Ahora, podríamos resolver la ecuación y
saber qué es lo que representa ese símbolo,
claro que si previamente ya supiéramos de qué se trata, pues entonces no sería una incógnita.
Otra situación sería cuando queremos establecer
la relación entre números, por ejemplo,
digamos, si yo estableciera esta relación
de, si tú me das un 3, yo te doy un 4,
si me das un 5, te doy un 6, si me dieras un
7.1 yo te daría un 8.1.
Y esto lo podríamos seguir extendiendo siempre,
siempre, siempre,
o sea que tú me dieras un número
y yo te regresara otro número.
Obviamente se ve que aquí no me alcanzaría,
ni el espacio ni el tiempo
y entonces podríamos plantear de otra manera este asunto, por ejemplo, si lo que tú me das,
le llamamos "x" y lo que yo te doy le llamamos "y" y observemos que ahora esta simple ecuación
me establece la relación de un infinito número de números, muchas "x" y muchas "y".
Por ejemplo, alguien puede decir, bueno, si
tú me das 3, le agrego 1 y te regreso 4,
tú me das 7.1, yo le agrego 1 y te regreso 8.1.
Y ésta es una manera elegante de representar
las relaciones, usamos "x" y "y" por razones
históricas y podríamos utilizar por ejemplo,
si tú me das una estrella, yo te regresaré...
mmm... digamos, una carita sonriente.
Y ésta es una manera válida de trabajar,
o sea, las letras son simplemente símbolos.